[siren wailing]
(Jones)
'Hold up. Who's that?'
Is that Jim?
'What the hell?'
What's up, guys?
- 'Yo!'
- How's it going?
What are you...
What are you doing?
How's crime tonight?
How's the rhyme tonight?
I don't even...
Terry, what are you doing...
What are you doing
with a cop car?
I bought the car
at Cop Car Mart.
- I got the--
- Cop Car Mart?
The uniform
at Uniform Junction.
I...
And then I got a gun
from Everybody Buying
A Gun Tonight
the gun store.
I saw a monster...
I thought I saw a monster.
- Okay, we're good.
- Stop it!
There's no bullets in it!
Okay. Okay, okay.
[gunshot]
Alright. Knock it off!
- Knock it off!
- Stop it, Terry.
I thought
there were no bullets.
(Jim)
'What the [bleep], Terry.'
- Hi.
- Oh, Jesus.
- What the [bleep] was that?
- 'Jim.'
- What was in that rag?
- Are you alright?
We don't chloroform
our friends.
Uh, he's been doing coke
back here.
Did you see this?
Look, he's got powder
all over his nose.
I've been baking a cake
for you guys as a surprise.
[Terry cries]
Hey, Terry!
- Hi!
- How's it goin'?
- I'm doing great, A-plus.
- 'Okay, good.'
I'm totally sober.
- That's great.
- It sucks.
- Good for you.
- I mean, I love it.
Yeah, we've gotten a report
of several reports, actually
that people have been finding
pubic hairs in their burritos.
'Yeah, you know anything
about that?'
No, that's awful!
Yeah, it is.
That seems a little peculiar
that you handle food.
I don't touch the food.
'So how do you, you don't
touch the food?'
I don't, it's on the tray.
I take it and I give it
to you and I say take it,
and don't put pubic hair in it.
I say that specifically.
Well, that's too bad
about the hair, I'm serious.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna call
the police.
- Okay.
- Well, somebody already did.
- Yeah, here we are.
- Oh.
- Sheriff's Department.
- Hello, we answered your call.
- Oh, that's right.
- 'What can we do for you, sir?'
Someone's putting pubic hair
in the tacos!
Okay, who do you think
that might be?
So...
So, um...can we get
a couple free tacos or...
Um, see what I can do,
Pedro's a little peeved at me.
What'd you do?
I put some pubic hair in one
of, I fell and I didn't...
- Come on. let's go.
- I know I said I didn't I--
- Let's go.
- I didn't mean that.
Come on, Terry, let's go.
What do you consider
your job skills to be?
[sighs]
- Skating...
- Yep.
That's good.
High-fiving...
Skating and high-fiving.
Low-fiving...
low five, the antithesis
of high five
- And?
- And singing.
Singing.
So, Terry,
what you're basically saying
is, you could be in
"Starlight Express"
if they ever, ever are bold
enough to mount it again.
- Yes.
Possible "Starlight Express"
understudy.
You're off drugs now?
You're totally clean?
I'm so clean, it's not
even ridiculous.
- Not even ridiculous.
Here's the thing,
I find that
eerily a little bit
disappointing
because if you're
not on drugs
if this is you
totally, totally clean
and you've missed
19 parole hearings
and you're working
at who let the clogs out?
That's kind of disappointing,
don't you think?
First of all,
I was voted the smartest
at my family reunion
like, hands down.
By the rest
of your family?
You can't put up two fingers
for the same thing.
You can't say you're smartest
at your family reunion,
hands down.
That's one thing.
I was voted smartest
in my family reunion...
- That's one.
- Hands down.
No. That's part
of the same sentence.
You're saying two
parts of the same sentence
part one of the sentence
end of the sentence.
Those aren't two things.